olivier martin ont beaucoup de bêtises
le fait au début j'en pense aux points
différence se fait savoir un tout petit
peu quatre élèves en 1959 le calcul
n'était pas bien compliqué pour passer
de l'ancien au nouveau franc il
s'agissait pour les français de desplat
t20 rose en 2002 pour le passage à
l'euro la faire se portent un petit peu
c'est les virgules zapater mélange quoi
fait prendre à fait
à peine 3 euros presque 2 euros 40 alors
pour aider à la conversion des français
se sont transformés en géo trouvetou au
ministère de l'économie monsieur reçoit
chaque jour les gadgets les plus
exotiques qui attendent d'être homologué
par bercy va vous avez d'excellentes
choses comme ça là qui sont pas
automatiques sont un peu compliquées qui
seront des choses qui sont comme ça
qu'ils sont plutôt sympathiques mais
pour les personnes âgées c'est pas très
facile à manier le convertisseur c'est
l'objet phare du passage à l'euro et
attention il ne s'agissait pas d'une
vulgaire calculette mais d'une heure est
elle s'appelle leur est grande comme une
carte de crédit elle propose un double
affichage en francs et en euros alors
vous avez l'euro déjà sélectionné et
vous tapez votre 70 un convertisseur
dans la poche et au poignet la
technologie prend le dessus cette montre
indique la date en aux leurs en bas
jusque là tout est normal mais elle
convertit aussi les francs en euros et
pour trier les huit nouvelles pièces de
monnaie jérôme a inventé le porte
monnaie qui trient les euros on y entre
les pièces en vrac et on se fout
quelques secondes
et voilà
annezin ça permet de faire l'appoint un
peu plus facilement plus sur coup de
faire l'apprentissage de l'euro d'une
manière plus pratique à la fois ludique
qui souhaitait sympathique et des porte
monnaie il y en a eu pour tous les goûts
l'euro a été source d'invention en tout
genre exemple avec cette créatrice en
2001 elle a créé une quarantaine
d'objets design des objets utiles
ludique qu'elle voulait joli et pratique
par exemple le collecteur franc euro
pour mettre ces derniers francs et on
pourra mettre après ses premiers euros
dans les petites poches et on a fait
aussi par exemple le tour du cou 6 55957
les inventions pour célébrer l'euro est
une invention pour mettre fin au franc
âmes sensibles s'abstenir car voici la
trouille aux deux en pleine action et
tous nos billets vont y passer 50 100
200 500 francs trouillot tu es sous vos
yeux au guichet comme de vulgaires
ticket de métro une trouille aux deux
une re est un collier 59 5 7 milliards
20 ans pour l'arrivée de l'euro les
français n'ont en tout cas pas manqué
d'imagination
[Musique]